you've thrown some bachelorette parties
in your day yeah I would think you would
be great if throwing a bachelorette
party do you ever take the the ladies
out to a strip club is that so that's
how we do yeah well yeah I mean not
everyone does that we'd this is the
theme of tonight's segment we go to
strip bars yes I mean for us I think
it's for girls sometimes I think it's
usually like a really last-minute idea
where you're sort of out and you're at a
club or whatever you're like but girls
are different at strip bars you know
girls end up like top well it depends on
what kind of strip bars you go to you
know if you go to like either like the
Chippendales type thing I've actually
never been to him and you've never been
to a male stripper I've even seen
thunder down under' I've never I've
never I haven't missed a show I don't
know I've never been to one of those you
know I've never been doing me I always
end up you know at the female strip
clubs and then but I don't I end up like
talking to everybody you know what I
mean
you kind of end up like I just sit with
the girls and the dancers yeah oh yeah
it's like oh it's your name I get all
the real names and you know we talk
about where they come from and when they
started dancing and I don't know it's
just kind of different for I think
sometimes for women
yeah it's funny because I've heard it's
an old saying that men look at women and
women look at other women I don't know
if that's true
but I think women can definitely very
much appreciate really appreciate other
women right yeah and when men and when
women look at you and and when women
and that when women look at men there
they're no they're not so much looking
at one they're not objectifying so much
one area as much as seeing the whole
package is that the idea
I think Matt I guess I'm asking I hope I
don't know I think first of all first of
all we graded on a scale I think I think
you know and I'm just gonna this is just
my own personal feelings I'm not gonna
make a generalize because everyone has a
different opinion for me I do really
love the female body I think it's really
beautiful the feminine is beautiful and
and the way femininity moves is is
incredible and I don't mean that and
just by going to a strip I mean that
general men are different you know it's
like it's just different it's you know
and and and so I think that there's I
think it's easier for women to sort of I
don't know appreciate each other's
diamond entity there it is it's just
different as different women are
different than guys yes yes God I think
all of us are tired of men now these
days yeah we are really matter tired of
men
you